can of the many books that you've
written now you have one in you co-wrote
entitled writing treatments that sell
and maybe you can hold it up so up and
see it it's cool cover there and first
off do we define what is a treatment
well this is one of the things that try
and I looked into when we wrote this
book because we kept getting asked that
question by clients you know what is a
treatment we have to explain it over and
over again and it suddenly occurred to
us what is a treatment ourselves and
what is their definition so we did a
survey of about 30 execs in television
and film and asked them that question
how would you define a treatment and we
asked them about ten other questions and
we really based the book on their
answers and basically the answer is that
a treatment is a relatively brief
written pitch of a story intended to be
dramatized as a motion picture for film
or television and it's written in user
friendly grammar free quick language
that is easy to follow and it contains
highlights the most important characters
and events the obligatory scenes in the
story that's what a treatment is now so
how long is the treatment relatively
brief three pages to say 15 pages once
it's past 15 20 it's getting no longer
relatively brief and there was no
industry agreement on it and basically
treatments range from 5 to 10 pages good
treatments and we recommend that because
the attention span of the who you're
dealing with
the audience your reader the buyer his
attention span is limited and you do not
want to extend it because he won't be
there she won't be there at the end of
the story if you make it too long so
that's basically what a treatment is and
it's used for two purposes it diagnoses
the faults in a story so you write a
treatment of your story to see the
faults in it so it's a diagnostic tool
and then you fix them and then it
becomes a sales tool because if people
are willing to read a treatment
they won't read a script because the
script is serious engagement
whereas treatment can be read relatively
quickly and those are it's used in every
part of the industry and and it's
different from a synopsis because the
synopsis is a dry fully detailed summary
of a story you'd find a synopsis in a
coverage for example but the treatment
is a pitch
it's the substitute for a live pitch
there can't be doing a webinar called
pitch perfect which is about pitching
and when you get the rare occasion to do
that but now with the internet we're
going to do with virtual pitching so
that people can actually pitch to a
producer and get an answer and the pitch
is extremely fortunate chance to sell
your story and again you do not want to
be preface it with anything you don't
want to reveal your personality that's
not what it's about you want to just
tell how strong your story is by showing
the story and a treatment is the best
you can do if you don't have the
opportunity to pitch life
so the treatment replaces a pitch and
it's what most people use and they use
it through email and through any other
method they have to hand a piece of
paper to someone else
you